this new dawn in america
is the moment we've been waiting for so
long
europe is ready for new start with our
oldest and
most trusted partner and this is why the
commission recently has adopted
a new forward-looking transatlantic
agenda
and it focuses on where we can together
join forces
to push for global change based on our
common values
interests and global influence
from climate change to health from
digitalization
to democracy these are global challenges
that need renewed and improved global
cooperation
and the european union and the united
states
must lead from the front and bring an
alliance of like-minded partners with us
there is of course no greater need for
global cooperation in the short
term than in tackling the pandemic
which has been so devastating on both
sides of the atlantic
i'm delighted that on day one as they
announced
the new american administration the
united states
will rejoin the paris agreement
this will be a very strong starting
point
for our new renewed cooperation and of
course
way more is to come the united states
are back
and europe stands ready to reconnect
with an old and trusted partner
to breathe new life in our cherished
alliance
you